over the past week I've spent a dozen
hours with warframe or with the new apex
legends and five in anthems open demo
period and as the week ended a question
struck me how long can this games as
service trend continued as entries in a
prevalent sub-genre these life style
games rely on players returning to them
as often as possible there are only as
good as their long-term cash-spending
player base overwatch does this through
holiday events destiny does it with
major expansions warframe hooks its
players with a drip feed of character
progression asking them to farm
resources across an array of complicated
systems for many players this model is
ideal rather than spending $60 on dozens
of games each year they can instead
focus their time and money on one or two
of them they can master their mechanics
and ideas catching up with friends on a
set schedule based around a weekly
rendezvous they can devote their time to
fewer virtual worlds but at the heart of
this development model is an inherent
problem as each new lifestyle game
releases the genre cannibalizes itself
players either move from one platform to
another or remain loyal to the games
they already know hear time is the most
valued quantity and eventually there
won't be enough to go around now this
problem isn't entirely new video game
developers have always competed for
players time and money with robust
feature lists and attractive box art
shooters introduced new maps MMO xanex
their existing worlds single-player
adventures paced their stories to keep
players engaged until the end only to
introduce a new game plus mode upon
completion theoretically this lends more
value to the players purchase and of
course value is always subjective but in
the case of lifestyle games the question
of value becomes even more complicated
this is due in large part to the notion
of an end game developers often consign
their best ideas to these later stages
from Destiny's explained raids to the
divisions cutthroat dark zones the mere
act of getting to these features could
take dozens if not hundreds of hours
only then can you see the fruits of your
labor and witness the full potential
value
of each game and of course barring any
prisoner of azkaban hourglass
shenanigans seeing the entirety of each
of these games is literally impossible
you almost have to decide where your
loyalties lie that's why this
development model is becoming
increasingly risky more so than any
other genre this one relies on player's
loyalty to be successful if a studio can
attract new players hook them and keep
them entertained it can recoup its money
with each new update expansion or micro
transaction so when I see Bioware a
company long known for its single-player
RPGs trying to break into the sphere I
can't help but worry as the release
approaches it's entering an arena that's
already low on real estate its competing
with the likes of fortnight destiny to
black ops or warframe Rainbow six siege
for honor apex legends monster hunter
world and even sea of thieves which has
seen a massive recent boost thanks to
prominent twitch players and of course
there's the elephant in the room
the division 2 which releases exactly
one month after anthem developer massive
entertainment has the clear advantage
here it has 3 years of experience with
the previous division to draw from it
has an avid existing fanbase following
every news story every update out of the
studio and its publisher Ubisoft if I'm
Bioware then this is the last game I
want breathing down my neck you might
look at anthem in the division 2 and
think they're completely different games
that wouldn't compete but they rely on
the same survival techniques
it's no secret that Bioware is a shadow
of its former self any RPG fan would
probably echo the sentiment even before
Mass Effect Andromeda is released with
its poor critical reception and
tumultuous launch the studio lost many
of its veteran members
what's more Andromeda's creator Bioware
Montreal was then absorbed into its
sister studio EA motive in the aftermath
from the outside looking in it seems as
if Bioware's very survival relies on
anthem being the next big thing a recent
report on Kotaku reinforces this notion
news editor Jason Schreyer spoke to
numerous Bioware employees who think the
studio's future is inextricably tied to
anthem
this comes after news that mark daraa
executive producer of the Dragon Age
franchise which has a sequel in some
stage of the
Elliman was moved to the anthem team
with Bioware Edmonton and bio are Austin
completely focused on the loot shooter
it's clear the developer is betting most
of its chips on anthem being a hit to be
clear I'm all for competition fueling
creativity in any video game genre and
from what at played of anthem during its
pre-release period I've had a lot of fun
despite how repetitive it can be I
thoroughly enjoy how smoothly it plays
and I can't wait to see the final
product yet as I said before this genre
relies on more than just good mechanics
and with the division - on the way and a
plethora of other lifestyle games still
going strong I can't help but see
Bioware as David facing off against a
dozen goliaths but of course if history
tells us anything about that age-old
story it's this the outcome is never set
in stone
[Music]